[Music]
the Royal kiddos for the win yet again
on Tuesday Prince Harry Megan Marco
Prince William and Kate Middleton joined
the Queen on the balcony at Buckingham
Palace to watch this spectacular fly
past in honor of the 100th anniversary
of the Royal Air Force willing Cates two
oldest kiddos Prince George and Princess
Charlotte weren't in attendance but
surprise they still managed to steal the
show the siblings were caught on camera
adorably making faces while watching the
festivities from a window in Buckingham
Palace three-year-old Charlotte has made
headlines with her iconic wave before
but there's nothing cuter than her dance
moves and cheeky face coupled with
four-year-old Georgia's excitement while
observing the crowds below the day
before the tiniest Royals were
surrounded by their parents grandparents
and aunts and uncles for their brother
Prince Louise christening
it's been a very small quite intimate
family christening I think on this one
the Queen decided that she was going to
graciously bow out
[Music]